Hay dos países en el mundo que siempre se
ponen como ejemplo de lo que no hay que hacer.
Dos países que durante mucho tiempo pareció
que iban a comerse el mundo pero que, sin
embargo, llevan décadas viviendo una especie
de crisis crónica. Una crisis de la que no
consiguen escapar.
¿Sabéis de qué países os estoy hablando?
Vale, uno desgraciadamente es Argentina, ese
era fácil . El otro, a 18.000 km de distancia,
es Japón.
[Aunque, un momento. Por supuesto esto no
quiere decir que los dos países sean iguales,
para nada. Es algo que hace muy poquito vimos
aquí en VisualPolitik en un vídeo que os
dejo en la descripción]
El caso es que cada vez que un país desarrollado
tiene problemas, Japón es el país que se
pone siempre como ejemplo de lo que no hay
que hacer.
(Remedios de Europa contra la japonización.
El débil crecimiento y la desaceleración
de la inflación pueden hacer que los europeos
teman repetir los errores de Japón)
Tal vez, amigos, la persona que mejor ha experimentado
esta evolución tan negativa de Japón durante
las últimas décadas ha sido, precisamente,
el emperador Akihito.
Me explico. El emperador en Japón no tiene
poder, pero lo cierto es que Akihito no ha
tenido mucha suerte.
Cuando llegó al trono en 1989 Japón parecía
comerse el mundo.
(Aquel mismo año de 1989 la compañía japonesa
Sony entraba en Hollywood por la puerta grande
comprando la Columbia Pictures;
la división inmobiliaria de la Mitsubishi
se hizo con el mismísimo Rockefeller Center,
las inversiones de las empresas japonesas
estaban por todas partes y las previsiones
apuntaban, a que la economía nipona superaría
incluso en pocos años a la mismísima economía
de los Estados Unidos)
Sin embargo, en apenas 3 años todo se vino
abajo.
La burbuja japonesa explotó, la bolsa de
Tokio se desplomó y la crisis se extendió
por todo el sistema financiero japonés. Los
años de fuerte crecimiento económico se
terminaron para siempre.
Comenzó una especie de caminata por el desierto,
más de dos décadas de estancamiento económico.
(Desde 1991, el crecimiento económico medio
ha sido de apenas el 0.9% anual,
la deuda pública pasó del 50 al 236% del
PIB;
China le arrebató el segundo puesto entre
las mayores economías del mundo,
las empresas japonesas perdieron terreno y
Japón se quedó prácticamente fuera de los
primeros puestos en la gran revolución de
internet.
¿El coste? Las jornadas laborales extenuantes
de 12 y más horas siguen siendo habituales,
los trabajadores japoneses apenas disfrutan
de 10 días de vacaciones al año y los salarios
reales son incluso más bajos que hace 3 décadas
Y ahí no termina todo. Estos años no solo
han sido malos desde el punto de vista económico,
también han sido muy convulsos en lo que
a la política se refiere. En estos 30 años,
Japón ha tenido 17 primeros ministros de
5 partidos políticos diferentes. ¡Una locura!)
Amigos, por si todo esto fuera poco, durante
los años de Akihito la población también
ha envejecido mucho y el país ha conocido
desastres como el Tsunami y el accidente nuclear
de Fukushima en 2011. Por no hablar de la
amenaza norcoreana...
¿Entendeis ahora por qué diantres decimos
que el emperador Akihito no ha tenido suerte?
Ahora bien, esperad un momento. Junto al manga,
el sushi y los carricoches para perros, esta
es la cara que últimamente siempre se muestra
del país nipón, pero, amigos:
¿acaso todo es malo en Japón?
¿Qué pasa si os digo que a lo mejor las
cosas no han sido del todo tan negativas como
se cuentan? ¿Y si de alguna forma Japón
estuviera volviendo a brillar?
En este vídeo, aquí en VisualPolitik, hemos
querido por una vez fijarnos en la mejor cara
del país nipón.
Y también, en una revolución social que
poco a poco, de forma sigilosa se está produciendo
y que puede suponer una referencia o al menos
todo un experimento para el resto del mundo.
Atentos.
(LA MEJOR CARA)
Japón lleva 3 décadas pasándolo mal, sumergido
en una especie de estancamiento o crisis crónica
que no consigue superar.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento. A pesar de
ello, sus números siguen siendo bastante
buenos.
[Es evidente que no os va a sorprender que
os diga que Japón sigue siendo un país muy
rico, eso lo sabemos todos.]
Pero, la pregunta es, ¿Cuánto de rico o,
mejor dicho, cuánto de próspero sigue siendo
el país del sol naciente?
Pues, amigos, podemos decir que Japón sigue
siendo uno de los 20 países de todo el mundo
dónde los hogares tienen más ingresos después
de pagar impuestos.
Con 28.641 dólares netos, Japón está a
la altura de países como Dinamarca, Finlandia
o los Países Bajos y por encima de Reino
Unido, Nueva Zelanda o Irlanda.
Y también es uno de los cinco o seis países
donde en promedio las familias tienen más
patrimonio financiero una vez descontadas
sus deudas.
(Al mismo tiempo es el país con mayor esperanza
de vida, uno de los países más seguros y
a nivel educativo uno de los mejores. En el
índice PISA están solo por detrás de Singapur.
Por su parte en I+D, en investigación y desarrollo,
con más de 150.000 millones de dólares invertidos
cada año, son el tercer país con mayor nivel
de gasto y el quinto mayor en términos de
PIB, tan solo por detrás de Corea del Sur,
Israel, Suecia y Taiwán.)
Y, amigos, aunque la deuda pública sea la
más alta del mundo, ni más ni menos que
un 237% del PIB, realmente no es algo tan
grave como parece a simple viste.
El gobierno japonés tiene muchas deudas,
sí, pero también muchos activos financieros,
de tal forma que la deuda neta se reduce hasta
aproximadamente el 150%
[Claro, no solo importa lo que debes sino
también lo que tienes]
Y eso no es todo. Además el principal acreedor
del gobierno es el banco central… lo que
en cierto modo quiere decir que el coste de
toda esa deuda ya se ha repartido entre los
japoneses durante las últimas 3 décadas:
Por ejemplo, con menos rentabilidad financiera,
con buena parte del capital pasando a manos
públicas por las compras de activos del Banco
Central y con menos salarios reales
En cualquier caso, por así decirlo, toda
la deuda está en manos de los japoneses.
Japón no tiene deuda externa, no es un deudor
sino todo lo contrario.
(Japón, China y Alemania principales acreedores
del mundo. Japón mantuvo su posición como
la nación acreedora más grande del mundo
por 22º año consecutivo)
Y a diferencia de otros países sus empresas
tampoco están enchufadas a la deuda.
Por ejemplo, en la Bolsa de Tokyo, la 4º
bolsa más grande del mundo, 6 de cada 10
empresas cotizadas no tienen deuda neta.
[Vaya, visto de esta forma, a pesar de todos
los problemas que el país tiene - que los
tiene - las cosas ya no parecen tan malas,
¿No creeis? ]
(De hecho en los últimos años, entre el
año 2007 y el año 2017, se ha producido
un efecto curioso.
Fijaos, la economía japonesa apenas crece,
eso es un hecho, pero como su población se
está reduciendo y su economía no tiene inflación,
el crecimiento real per cápita [que al fin
y al cabo es lo que determina el nivel de
bienestar] ha crecido al nivel de Estados
Unidos y por encima de países como Francia
o Reino Unido.)
¿Sorprendido?
En todo esto, amigos, ha tenido mucho que
ver la explosión económica del continente
asiático.
Al fin y al cabo Japón tiene como vecinos
a países como China, Vietnam o la India,
donde, por ejemplo, Suzuki, una compañía
automovilística japonesa acapara algo más
del 50% de todo el mercado de coches de la
India.
Estamos hablando de miles de millones de consumidores
potenciales.
¿Otro ejemplo? Fijaos en lo que ha ocurrido
con el turismo.
(Tradicionalmente Japón ha sido un país
con pocas turistas. Claro, estaba muy lejos
de los países desarrollados.
Sin embargo en los últimos años casi que
se está convirtiendo en todo un parque temático.
Japón es el país donde más crece la llegada
de turistas en todo el mundo.
En poco tiempo, gracias en gran medida a los
visitantes chinos, el número de turistas
extranjeros ha pasado de poco más de 6 millones
en el año 2011 a más de 31 millones en 2018.
Y ojo porque las previsiones hablan de que
esta cifra podría superar los 60, 60 millones
para 2030.)
Evidentemente todo esto supone un montón
de nuevos empleos. Pero su población es la
más envejecida del mundo y de hecho se reduce
cada año. Entonces, ¿Cómo cubrir todos
esos nuevos trabajos?
Amigos es aquí donde entra en juego la revolución
social impulsada por el Primer Ministro, Shinzo
Abe.
Atentos porque Japón se está convertido
en todo un experimento sobre cómo enfrentarse
al envejecimiento demográfico. [Y creo que
os va a sorprender]
(LA REVOLUCIÓN SOCIAL)
Vale, en Japón lo tienen claro: en un país
tan envejecido que espera que su población
se contraiga fuertemente durante las próximas
décadas tan solo la productividad y la inversión
en tecnología y robots les puede salvar.
Pero, amigos, eso es algo que lleva tiempo…
y desde luego para poder invertir todo lo
que necesitan tienen que lograr ser una economía
próspera, así que la pregunta que todos
podemos hacernos es:
¿Cómo puede puede una economía estancada
recuperarse y mantener controladas las finanzas
públicas mientras la población envejece
a toda velocidad - con lo que eso supone en
pensiones y gasto sanitario?
Pues amigos, Shinzo Abe cree que a corto plazo
es indispensable incrementar la participación
laboral, el porcentaje de personas que trabajan,
que es precisamente lo que está pasando en
Japón:
Pero, ¿os habéis dado cuenta? ¿Cómo están
logrando incrementar el número de trabajadores
en un país donde la población se está reduciendo
y envejeciendo a toda velocidad. ¿Qué diantres
están haciendo en Japón?
Pues amigos, la respuesta es que en el país
nipón, Shinzo Abe está liderando toda una
revolución social.
Veréis, por un lado el gobierno está impulsando
planes para que las personas se jubilen más
tarde e, incluso, atentos, para que los jubilados
vuelvan al trabajo.
[Evidentemente a trabajos menos exigentes
y con turnos más cortos.]
Esto ha hecho que ya más de la mitad de todos
los hombres japoneses de entre 65 y 70 años
estén trabajando. Más del doble promedio
en los países de la OCDE, [que aglutina a
casi todos los países más desarrollados.]
¿Habéis visto la película “el becario”
de Robert de Niro? Pues… algo así.
(Por otro lado, el gobierno está impulsando
también un histórico incremento de la participación
laboral femenina, que en Japón ha sido tradicionalmente
no muy alta.
Japón está viviendo una transformación
enorme. El número de mujeres trabajando y
ocupando puestos de liderazgo está creciendo
con muchísima fuerza.
Este cambio se ha impulsado mediante lo que
se ha conocido como el “Womenomics”, una
política que por ejemplo ha incrementado
los servicios de guarderías, incentivado
los contratos a tiempo parcial o alentado
a las empresas a ajustar sus horarios a las
necesidades de las mujeres con hijos.
De esta forma, hoy Japón es uno de los países
donde un mayor porcentaje de mujeres están
trabajando)
Pero amigos, a pesar de todas estas medidas,
la economía japonesa necesita muchos más
trabajadores. De hecho, hay tantas vacantes
que actualmente hay más de 150 puestos de
trabajo por cada 100 candidatos.
Sí, los habéis escuchado bien. Hay más
empleos disponibles que candidatos.Muchos
más.
Por eso en los últimos años Shinzo Abe está
derribando lo que hasta ahora ha sido todo
un tabú para la sociedad japonesa.
(LA LLEGADA DE SAVIA NUEVA)
Desde tiempos inmemoriales Japón ha sido
uno de los países más cerrados a la inmigración
de todo el planeta. [Precisamente es algo
que os contamos hace ya un tiempo en VisualPolitik]
En Japón, la población inmigrante apenas
supone el 1,8% del total. Uno de los porcentajes
más bajos, sino el más bajo de todos los
países desarrollados.
Sin embargo, amigos, eso ahora está cambiando.
(Japón a Asia: danos a tus jóvenes, a tus
trabajadores cualificados, a tus trabajadores
ansiosos) "
Desde que Shinzo Abe llegó al poder en el
año 2012 el número de extranjeros se ha
duplicado.
Y ahí no va a quedar todo. En diciembre del
año 2018, Japón aprobó nuevas leyes para
impulsar la llegada de población inmigrante.
(Necesitamos liberarnos del pensamiento convencional.
Crearé un Japón que pueda atraer a grandes
talentos de todo el mundo ".)
Amigos, Las nuevas regulaciones contemplan
dos nuevos status para la población extranjera.
Por un lado, un estatus muy atractivo para
atraer los trabajadores más cualificados,
que podrán instalarse en Japón junto a sus
familias prácticamente de forma indefinida.
Por otro lado, un nuevo status para que un
montón de industrias puedan traer a trabajadores
menos cualificados. Aquí las condiciones
son más limitadas, pero aún así la nueva
regulación busca acabar con todos los problemas
y las malas condiciones que estos trabajadores
extranjeros habitualmente sufrían, algo de
lo que ya os hablamos en este otro vídeo.
En fin amigos, Japón tiene muchos, muchísimos
problemas, os hemos hablado de ellos un montón
de veces y lo haremos en el futuro. Pero también
tiene motivos para seguir siendo uno de los
países más ricos del mundo. ¿En qué quedará
esta
revolución social?